Bakiam
Boryran
[laughs]
The companions, the
Shiites, the Shiites of
Bahrain, may God bless him and grant him peace,
Arab you Arab Arab
so you
how you do
n't know
you the book understand the meaning of
it Allah
statement
shows other take in the book
will never be able to end
they will go to
events that happen in the Quran, God Almighty,
mention, and if two groups of believers
fight each other, God Almighty, its
supporters, the supporters of
Muhammad,
God, the followers of the
Sunnah.
So
without
someone who knows the Quran, someone who knows
what he is doing, that's why you be
know
[music]
you go the
imams, the imamate, the Children of
Israel, the
imamate of the Children of Israel, the imam of Adam, the Shiites,
God, Shiites
[laughs] The
Quran, creed,
reading,
creed,
foundation, the protected ones,
12 Children of Israel, Children of Israel, Children of Israel, he is
12 leaders, my love, 12 leaders are in the Quran,
its interpretation, offspring,
some of them from others, and God is All-Hearing, All-Knowing,
clear, you know, I didn't understand you, this is in Arabic
In Arabic, God chose Adam, Imran,
and Noah over all the worlds, descendants of one another, not
descendants of one another. God, by God, I'm not raising my
voice, my dear, understand? No, I'm here to explain to
people. Raise your voice, no one will hear me. He
says the Companions and the Ansar, God mentioned them. God did not mention them. He says, "And the first to embrace Islam of the Muhajireen and the
Ansar and those who followed them in goodness -
God is pleased with them." A clear verse, understand? And those around you... Continue, and those around
you from the hypocrites. Okay, what about the hypocrites who persisted in
hypocrisy? Give me a verse that says that among the Muhajireen were hypocrites.
No, no, and those around you...
What about the hypocrites? God revealed a whole chapter, Surah Al-
Munafiqun (The Hypocrites), in the Quran.
God Almighty is addressing the Prophet about them, those who were with him, and among the
Ansar and the Muhajireen were
hypocrites. And they guided you as you
wish. Let's continue now in the Quran. God, with you,
the Muhajireen, are fair. A verse: Not everyone in the city
lives among the Muhajireen. We know what we know.
Continue. There are hypocrites, there are Jews, but in the
Quran, every time God mentions the Muhajireen, He never
said...  In the Quran, it is stated that among the Muhajirun (
immigrants) are hypocrites who are Ansar (helpers). The one who praises them is praising the
Muhajirun and Ansar. Are you more knowledgeable about the Muhajirun than
God, or is God more knowledgeable? Okay, the question of the hypocrite is revealed. Answer
the question. God knows best. Of course, I am... Okay, so
God praised the Muhajirun, so you must come to me. He
praised them all, he praised them all. Come to me. And whoever
among you turns back on his heels... Who among the Muhajirun turns back on his heels? Who among the Ansar? Or not? No,
listen, my dear brother. Who turned back? No, answer me. No,
you are innocent. Just listen to me.
Answer me the question. Who among you turns back? Who turned back?
Take gifts. No, no, just listen to me. Who among you turns back on his heels? It will not
harm God at all. Talk about the black of Al Imran.
Talk about the master of Al Imran. No, my brother, about
apostasy. People turned back on this. It is not a matter of faith. This is not something
I will talk about, my
brother. Just listen to me. You don't distort, don't change, no,
without distorting the verse. And whoever among you turns back on his
heels...
God is the One who... And whoever...  This is what you're saying, okay? Surah
Al-Munafiqun (The Hypocrites) was revealed about the hypocrites. Who are the
hypocrites? Ubayy ibn Sal is hypocrisy. What is hypocrisy? Okay,
explain hypocrisy to me. What is hypocrisy? Hypocrisy is pretending to be a
believer outwardly while being an unbeliever inwardly. Okay, but what about the
greater hypocrites? The scope of the verse about the hypocrites? Was it revealed about
some of the Companions? No, it wasn't revealed about them at all.
The Companions are the Muhajirun (immigrants) and the Ansar (helpers). I'm not talking
about the Muhajirun, I'm talking about the Ansar.
God praised the Ansar in the Quran,
of course, He praised them a lot, not just in the Quran.
I'm asking, why did God mention the
followers of the attackers, the Ansar, clearly and not mention the
followers of your Ahl al-Bayt (family of the Prophet) clearly? Why, my friend? Just
listen to me. First thing, the first point is that God
Almighty mentions in the Quran, He
mentions in the Quran, "Offspring, some of them from others. And God is Hearing and Knowing. Indeed,
God has chosen..." Do you know what this means?
Followers, meaning offspring, some of them from others. You're not in the Quran.
Abu Jahl is from the lineage of Abraham, my brother. Offspring, some of them
from...  Some of Abu Jahl is from the descendants of Abraham,
my beloved. Descendants, some from each other. This Abu Jahl, is he Abu Jahl
or not? It's not clear. Excuse me, excuse
me, my beloved, but I'll excuse you. I swear to God, I swear to God, the
Holy Quran is about the establishment of the Caliphate. Just listen to me. There are
four Caliphs whom God appointed. Mention a
verse in the Quran that clearly states
four Caliphs in the Quran after the Prophet. There isn't one.
If there isn't, then be quiet and don't keep making things up. You say there's no proof, no proof. The Sunnis say, "
And today I have perfected for you your religion and have been pleased with you and completed My favor upon you and have approved for
you Islam as religion." O
Messenger, convey that which has been revealed to you. Understand? I'm
telling you, understand. Just listen to me in Arabic. Let me finish.
Why are you stopping me? Let me finish, my
brother. Ghadir, Ghadir, what? Stop. What is your Ghadir? Let me finish.
Let me finish,
people. Look, he doesn't let anyone finish and talk about the
topic. My beloved,
I answered you.
God Almighty established the Caliphate after the
Caliphate.
[Laughter]
Your brother, no  I'll answer you, I'll answer you. God clarified in
the Quran the appointment of the caliphate after the Messenger of
God, and He will have mercy on him. Witness, give me a verse, oh
Muhammad, convey what was revealed to you. What is in it, what is in it, Muhammad, convey it. Oh,
Muhammad, no, no, no, stop, just
give us a chance. This is an appointment, an appointment for the caliphate. It
exists. Ali ibn Abi Talib after the Messenger, and
whoever wants to accept it, accepts, and whoever doesn't want to accept it.
Okay, a question: Muhammad appoints from his side? The Quran appoints,
God appoints for him. Muhammad, I didn't understand you. I'm
telling you, after the Messenger of God,
God made, listen to me, before the Messenger of God, there was
no caliphate. God Almighty made
Moses his successor, who was his successor? Who was his successor? But answer us
about Aaron. Aaron, no, Aaron before Moses, did he leave a successor with his people
or not? Don't tell me he didn't leave a successor with his
people. Excuse me, you asked me about a successor after
Moses. Aaron died before Moses. Successor
40. Yes, Aaron was a successor. Yes, the
sheikhs, scholars, men,
and women of the Children of Israel. Yes, any successor. This is a caliphate. Are the Children of Israel
Israel or the Muslims? Do you understand, my brother?
No, you answer me. I want to continue. God
Almighty, my answer is my question. God says, "O you
who have believed, prescribed for you is what the Children of Israel said: '
Fast.'" And we are the ones who prevail. God said, "Fast." God made it easy.
I'm not talking.
Listen, he's not talking about the Children of Israel,
my dear. He's talking about the previous nations,
before the Messenger of God, the prophets who preceded the Messenger of
God. God appointed successors for them. It's not in my hands or yours to appoint
successors. God appoints the successor after the
Prophet. The caliphate does
n't leave the descendants. Who is the successor of the
Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him? Ali ibn Abi Talib.
He is the successor of the Messenger, but it's in your books, not yours. Listen to me, listen to me. It's in your books
that Ali pledged allegiance to
Abu Bakr al-Siddiq. What do you have?
God says, and you tell me Ali ibn Abi Talib
will give me Ali as
caliph? My dear,
God loves you. You mix up your topics.
You're just confused.
What are you, an Arab? Explain to me why you didn't understand me.
I understand, and I have the right to understand, but you're arguing with the Children of
Israel, my brother. No, God  I'm telling you,
Adam, come on, Adam, make people laugh.
People want to laugh. Is this your religion? Are these the morals of a
Muslim? Are these your morals? Michael Jackson, these are the morals of a
Muslim. May God guide you. I'm asking you a question. Adam,
peace be upon him, Adam, the question is about him. Adam,
peace be upon him, after that, let him speak. Let him be a Muslim. What's it to you? It's none of your
business. Just listen to me. God is angry. You're not angry?
No, I'm not angry. I'm angry
about Islam, whose image you're distorting.
I swear by God Almighty, you're tarnishing
the reputation of Islam and waging war against Islam, the religion of
God.
You're telling me about the Ansar? So, with your evidence,
God says, "The Ansar followed." The Ansar are people who followed,
not descendants of one another. God
made descendants of one another. Do
you know who they are? The family of Yasin. You have the
settings. Welcome. May God guide us and guide you. May God
guide us. And I have one last question. One last question. One last
question. What is your opinion about what is happening now between
Zionist Israel and Shiite Iran?
Answer us in front of everyone. Oppressors with oppressors,
oppressors with oppressors. He watches. And Gaza, are they
oppressors? Never.  The invaders are our brothers, and God will grant them
victory. I don't have the ability, but you do. Support them.
Yes, you're a liar. I'm going to the video. I swear to
God, Iran is an oppressor, and Israel is an oppressor. And what are you doing? You have
n't paid for the Sunnis in Iraq. Answer me!
Run after the Sunnis in Iraq! You're a liar, the most famous liar!
I swear to God, you're a liar! People, Iran is Islam,
supporting Muslims, the glory of Islam. You are the
glory of Islam. You
have money in this area. You say, "We will punish you." You give us money. Is this your Islam? Is this the Islam of Muhammad?
People, this is the Islam of
Muhammad. This is the Islam of
Muhammad. This is the Islam of Muhammad. Enough, my friend!
No, stop this
Islam that God brought you. You are a killer, and
the Jews and Christians will never be pleased with you until you follow their religion.
You followed their religion. May God curse the Jews
and Christians. You are
Aisha. Aisha is with God. No, no,
God doesn't include me with her. Why would God include me with the
Prophet? He says he's wrong. No, by God, it's not dissimulation. I swear to God, out of
respect for the Prophet, I say Aisha wronged the
Prophet. She wronged him against your will. She wronged him, by God!  You made a mistake, go
look at your novels and books, don't turn away.
Come here, Aisha, Aisha, praise God, he can't answer, he can't
answer
about Yemen, he can't answer about Iran.
Oh God,
you are unjust and a liar, a liar, by God
Almighty, a liar. God will hold you accountable. That's it, that's it.
When
someone comes, anyone, discuss, any reasonable Shiites,
reasonable Shiites, if we were in the comments, what would the
sheikh of her offspring say to each other, some of them apostatize, repeating
sometimes, the time of the
Sayyid, the Sunnis, praise be to
God, Bahraini,
Majlisi, Nimatullah, the Algerian, infidel, Muslim, my
brother,
Bahraini, Majlisi, Qomi,
known,
Shiites,
Shiites, good, 12, Islam,
you know, is the Sunnis, the
Sunnis, the
Salafis, the Salafis,
morals,
love them, however, we, may
God bless